[Music]
straight ahead on loan crime daily
disgrace attorney michael avenatti hopes
to reach a plea deal on more federal
charges plus the candy the dog trial
could the civil case lead to legal
reform and mr on january 11 2019 did you
stab your husband
i did
yes defendant and accused killer
danielle redlich takes the stand but
first johnny depp versus amber heard
hear more of heard's first interview
post verdict law on crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmeyer in a
continuation of her exclusive today
interview amber heard touched on the
topic of free speech in america
nearly two weeks ago a virginia jury
largely sided with johnny depp awarding
him 10 million dollars in compensatory
damages and 5 million in punitive
damages heard was granted a smaller win
in her counter suit when jurors awarded
her 2 million dollars in compensatory
damages over comments made by depp's
attorney adam waldman she was given
nothing for punitive damages the
verdicts came after six weeks of
testimony stemming from allegations that
heard defamed depp in her 2018
washington post op-ed about domestic
violence while depp suit heard for 50
million heard counter suit a hundred
million doubling down on abuse claims in
her first interview since the verdict
hurd stressed the importance of the
first amendment and discussed the
differences in depths united states and
united kingdom defamation trials
there is another trial handled it with
the same dealt with the same substantive
issues that had even more evidence in in
fact mine
my evidence was largely kept out really
important pieces of evidence kept
out done differently handled differently
by a judge instead of a jury
some evidence is admissible in a uk
court that is not admissible in a u.s
court do you think that maybe he just
had better lawyers i will
say his his lawyers did certainly a
better job of distracting the jury from
the real issues
this is uh
this is not only about
our first amendment right to speak but
here's the thing about the first
amendment the first amendment protects
free speech
it doesn't protect lies that amount to
defamation and that was the issue in the
case yes exactly you can't go into the
free speech does not protect you if you
you know go into a crowded theater and
you scream fire we get the concept of
free speech from the greeks my
understanding of what that means is not
just the freedom to speak
it's a freedom to speak truth to power
but truth is the word
yes that was the issue and that's all i
spoke
and i spoke it to power and i paid the
price
meanwhile there has also been confusion
about the damages heard was ordered to
pay dep following the verdict herds
attorney elaine benarhoff indicated she
did not have the money to pay her
ex-husband in a sit-down interview with
law and crime network's own jesse weber
johnny depp's attorney said the trial
was not about the money but instead
about regaining dep's reputation
one of the things that's come out is
people have been wondering
you know the monetary judgment right the
10.35 million there's been discussion
would johnny wave that uh that you know
this has been more about the moment this
is more about winning back his
reputation his career and not the money
do you see him tend to enforce the
judgment um great question
is johnny testified and we mentioned in
closing this is not about the money for
johnny this is all about getting this
light back being able to work and
restoring his reputation so money is not
the primary object for him
so we expect there to be some
discussions but
he sticks to that money this wasn't
about money
joining us today is co-host terry austin
and long crime legal analyst kirk nermey
kirk
what do you make of herd's post-verdict
interview so far could it affect any
future appeals
well i don't think it could affect any
future appeals brian because the court
of appeals is going to make their
decision based on the trial transcripts
and the trials transcripts alone and the
legal issues and how they relate but
when we talk about the ultimate
resolution of this case and we saw mr
chu talk about negotiations it could
really affect what happens post-verdict
if you will because she's kicking the
bear she's almost doubling down on her
defamation claims and in that sense that
might motivate mr depp to decide to
collect on his 8.35
victory yeah i mean i mean that's a
great point there and of itself terry
let's get back to those damages or let's
get into those damages now that kurt
brought it up has depth team address the
claim that heard cannot afford to pay
her ex what happens if she really
doesn't have the money
well you know it's interesting ben too
was very careful with his words in that
interview he basically said what he had
said during closing and what depp said
on the stand that he didn't do this for
the money he did it for his reputation
trying to gain that back having said
that they should go after the money and
they probably will i think kirk is right
she's doubling down on what she said and
that basically is defamation and it is
an incentive for him to collect and what
he can do is put a lien on her wages
they can work out a structural
settlement but i do think at the end of
the day he should collect and he
probably will collect it may take some
time but it makes sense as a matter of
principle to go after that money
particularly since she's still saying
the same thing she's been saying from
the beginning all right we'll see how
johnny deposit attorneys handle that of
course you can't get blood from a rock
so to speak so as you said terry it
might just take a little bit longer but
we'll eventually get there i'm curious
to see if he says you know what donate
pledge whatever word you want to use to
actual victims of domestic violence that
could be another thing he does but we'll
of course keep an eye on this as it
develops
still ahead on law and crime daily a
beloved dog is shot and killed in front
of its owner we look ahead to the civil
trial but first accused husband killer
danielle redlich takes the stand we take
you inside the courtroom for her
testimony
[Music]
welcome back the state rested's case and
the defendant takes the stand in the
florida trial of danielle redlich a
woman accused of stabbing her husband to
death three years ago red lake claims
she killed her husband michael redlich
in self-defense when she stabbed him in
their winter park home in 2019. the two
had been married for nearly 20 years and
had two children together danielle's
defense attorney said their relationship
had a history of abuse and cheating the
couple had reportedly filed for divorce
by the time of michael's death 911 calls
revealed danielle initially told
dispatchers that michael had stabbed
himself and had a heart attack
investigators say she waited several
hours to call for help danielle is
charged with second-degree murder and
evidence tampering and could be
sentenced to life in prison if convicted
danielle and michael's daughter jaden
took the stand on monday the judge
didn't allow her testimony to be filmed
but she told jurors her mother was a
primary source of toxicity for her
parents relationship the defense called
danielle as their first witness on
tuesday she testified to why she says
she stabbed her husband
mr like on january 11 2019 did you stab
your husband
i did
yes
why
um he was suffocating me i couldn't
breathe and he had me pinned down
can you explain more
i was scared and
you know it's just in fear for my life i
he had thought he snapped and i could
die
why were you in fear for your life why
did you think that you could die in that
circumstance
um just
how he had me pinned down and i couldn't
breathe and so um just the look in his
eye his anger
um and i couldn't get away
you trying to get away i was you're
trying to use something besides a weapon
to get away
yes do you have any choice but to use a
weapon to get away
no how many times did you stab him
once
terry now that danielle redlick has
taken the stand do you think her story
is believable or credible
you know she had to take the stand brian
because she had so many different
stories she talked about a heart attack
she talked about she stabbed him then
she said he stabbed himself so basically
she had to explain to that jury what
really happened and she's coming across
fairly credibly she's talking about
domestic violence that occurred before
that fateful evening she's talking about
other times he hit her she said she's
called 9-1-1 in the past she said she's
gone to the hospital in the past she's
talking details about when she went to
mcdonald's and what happened and who
texted whom
so she's coming across a big credible as
far as i'm concerned her affect however
brian is not good she's really stiff she
has no emotion and i think at the end of
the day that's probably going to hurt
her credibility with the jury yeah i
would expect
i thought it would come first but maybe
it comes second that there would be an
expert to talk about battered women
syndrome because that's what she's kind
of describing and maybe lay the
groundwork hey maybe i'm jumping the gun
maybe that'll come later but we'll show
that as it comes up kirk what do you
think of the prosecution uh strongest
argument could be in the
cross-examination in questioning daniel
redlich
danielle sorry terry's right terry's
right she's coming across very credible
now so they're going to have to attack
her with fact facts that are undisputed
and as terry kind of mentioned we had
some different and convoluted stories
right we have that he had a heart attack
that he stabbed himself and she said she
stabbed him and there's other facts that
are really bad that make her look bad
right the 11 hours said she didn't call
911 because she couldn't find her phone
but hours later she found it to go on a
dating app and she waits again that 11
hours before she picks up the phone and
calls 9-1-1 to make her reports so i
think the prosecution is going to want
to hone in on that set of facts those
hours right before the killing so they
concentrate it right on that day because
that's where the state wants the jury to
focus and not any better women syndrome
that might exist beyond the scope of
this particular day in this particular
event yeah it's going to be interesting
to see how they put that all together
and of course we're continuing to follow
this case capital gavel make sure to
check out the law and crime trial
network for more also in florida the
sentencing phase continues for convicted
killer alan wade on tuesday a forensic
psychologist testified about wade's past
trauma more than a decade ago wade and
co-defendants michael james jackson
tiffany cole and bruce nixon were
convicted in the murders of reggie and
carol sumner prosecutors say the group
dug a hole in a remote wooded area
before kidnapping the sumners the four
then stole from the couple's home and
forced him into the trunk of their own
car they later forced a couple to share
their bank account information before
burying them alive wade was originally
given the death penalty but a change in
florida law now requires a unanimous
recommendation from jurors for the death
penalty on tuesday jurors heard from a
forensic psychologist who described how
wade's trauma could have affected his
actions
i found instances of physical abuse
of sexual abuse
witnessing neighborhood violence and
being bitten and shot at these are
specific traumatic incidents and i also
found
intense stressors that are also very
chronic and even though they're not like
traumatic in the sense that they don't
cause that um
they don't involve the loss of life for
example right
but they are very uh
harmful and they can lead to the same
kind of damage that than trauma could
need people who go through the same
negative experiences might have
different problems some people might
develop depression some people might
develop anxiety some people might become
violent so it's very different
it's also very important to look at the
developmental stage of where the person
experience the trauma so we know that
early trauma has a more negative impact
on the brain
coming up on law and crime daily just
days after a prison sentence is handed
down michael avenatti faces even more
federal charges plus the candy the dog
case we look ahead to the civil trial in
florida
[Music]
welcome back we're looking ahead now to
the so-called candy the dog civil trap
as a florida dog owner works to bring
justice for the death of his beloved dog
and companion the case dates back to
2016 when then 25 year old zachary
deterly shot and killed candy the
terrier mix saying he feared for his
life at the time candy's owner rodney
jacobson was working on his boat
jenkinson previously arranged to store
his boat on diddly's father's property
candy was off leash when she approached
dieterly he says the dog
was in an attack stance after that
didley pulled out his revolver and shot
the dog twice the sarasota county
sheriff's office says didily was not
charged because he had a permit to carry
the weapon they say he was also within
his rights to use deadly force because
he feared for his life jacobson says
kanye had no history of aggression and
was only barking at deadly because he
she did not recognize him he says the
ultimate goal of the trial is for the
sarasota sheriff's office to determine
the shooting was not justified and to
file criminal charges against dieterle
opening statements are expected to be
presented this week
terry to start was dearly within his
legal rights to shoot and kill the dog
if he feared for his life what sort of
outcome could we expect in this civil
suit
you know what brian from a criminal
perspective if he really feared for his
life and if he owned that firearm
legally then yes he had a right to shoot
and kill the devil sadly but from a
civil perspective they could really
recover some damages from this claim
they are suing for intentional
infliction of emotional distress and as
you know that is one of my favorite
causes of action and they're suing for
negligence they're suing for trespass to
chattel so they have a number of causes
of action where they could recoup a
bunch of money from that you know claim
if in fact they do win so if they can
prove that they really were harmed and
that they went for medical treatment and
they had psychological problems they
could recover quite a bit of money even
if there was a right to shoot the dog
yeah hey i'm biased i've got a 75 pound
doberman that's uh trained in shits in
training when you say attack stance that
to me sounds defending because if a
terrier wants you it goes after you but
kirk that's a whole other story let's go
to your question jacobson says he hopes
the case will spark change in florida
law so is it legal to shoot and kill
someone's pet
no michael is brian excuse me as we just
saw you know it is not legal to just
haul off and shoot somebody as terry
said the reason that the arrest didn't
take place is because they felt he was a
legal gun owner and well within his
rights to
shoot if he felt like he his life was in
jeopardy but this case is really
important i think in terms of dog
ownership in florida because what
constitutes somebody's life in jeopardy
as it relates to a dog attack this dog
was in a stance as you mentioned brian
and
what gives someone the right to think
that that stance is going to turn into
chaos it's hard for me to believe that
mr dearly was really really in fear for
his life with this dog so i think this
case really is it might set some
important precedent in terms of holding
people accountable for these kind of
shootings yeah because as you know self
defense is both objective and subjective
i'm not criticizing his objective i'm
asking about the objective but we'll
continue to follow this case and in
tennessee a man convicted in his
five-year-old son's murder seeks a new
trial saying there wasn't enough
evidence to convict him in the first
place a jury convicted joseph daniels
last year finding him guilty of felony
murder in the death of his five-year-old
son joe clyde daniels known by the
nickname baby joe he was also charged
with first-degree murder but the jury
bumped that down to guilty of
second-degree murder jurors also
returned a guilty verdict on aggravated
child abuse initiating a false report
and tampering with evidence he was
sentenced to 51 years to life in prison
according to tennessee news outlet wtvf
daniels argues there was insufficient
evidence at trial to convict now saying
his conviction should be thrown out the
motion will likely move to the state
court of appeals but for now he will ask
the dixon to county judge for a noon
trial earlier this year joe clyde's
mother crystal daniels pled guilty to
serve 15 years for aggravated child
abuse she cannot appeal
when we come back michael avenatti is
back in court why the disgrace attorney
is expected to take a plea deal as part
of his latest lawsuit
[Music]
welcome back a months-long federal trial
in california is coming to an end as
closing arguments were presented tuesday
in the trial of ramesh sanibalwani the
former ceo of theranos and former
boyfriend of its founder elizabeth
holmes bowani faces a dozen federal
charges accused of defrauding investors
and customers after touting theranos as
having a revolutionary breakthrough
technology in blood testing prosecutors
seek to convince a jury that bowani
conspired with homes to scam investors
out of millions of dollars similar to
holmes's federal trial prosecutors
brought in many of the same witnesses
but unlike her trial the defendant sonny
balwani chose not to take the stand in
his own defense bowani's defense argued
holmes was in charge she was convicted
in january of four of the 11 counts of
conspiracy and wire fraud that was that
she was charged with but acquitted of
four counts alleging she deceived
patience her jury was unable to come to
a decision on three other counts but
last month holmes urged a judge to
overturn her verdict she is said to be
sentenced in september
also in california disgraced attorney
michael avenatti says he plans to plead
guilty to charges in california which
allege he stole millions of dollars from
former clients the announcement to
change his plea comes just one month
before avenatti was set to go on trial
for embezzlement and fraud charges he is
charged with 36 counts of fraud
embezzlement perjury failure to pay
taxes and other financial crimes accused
of stealing five million dollars from
his clients and just two weeks ago
avenatti was sentenced to four years in
federal prison for identity theft and
wire fraud as he is convicted of
stealing nearly 300 thousand dollars
from his former client stormy daniels
she was supposed to receive the money in
connection with a book contract avenatti
is already serving time for a separate
conviction of trying to extort millions
of dollars from nike the disgrace's
lawyer has asked to schedule a hearing
to formally submit a plea change he is
set to go to trial at the end of july
kirk with ebenady's serving time
basically all over the country in
federal courts uh in prison on wire
fraud and other charges what kind of
plea deal do you think he'll strike with
california
my guess is he's really hoping that by
accepting responsibility and of course
nobody knows the evidence more better
than him he knows what he's up against
so i think he's going to hope that he
can go to the court accept
responsibility for everything he's done
be open and honest about it say that
he's doing it for altruistic reasons and
go forward and hope that the sentencing
is concurrent or that
the bulk of it is concurrent so he
minimizes the time he spends in federal
custody yeah concurrent and consecutive
are going to be really big things for
him but terry guilty in california new
york and probably new cases are going to
pop up after this but where does
avenatti serve jail time and how does
that work
you know the thing is they're going to
have to work out an agreement as kurt
already said we know that he was
sentenced to 30 months for that nike
extortion out in california he's been
sentenced as you said to four years in
new york for the stormy daniels case and
now these new charges he really could
receive a large sentence it's a huge
case he's being charged with stealing 10
million dollars in settlement funds from
his clients and he does want to be
accountable he's accepting
responsibility and for all of that they
may be able to work out a deal that he
serves in a better facility maybe
california we'll see how it plays out
thank you both and thank you for joining
us here on law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
you